Point exchange of view on women's role
in the right and freedom protest in Iran
and government Crackdown in the presence
of different uh people and I represent
them after so it has been now weeks that
Iranian Society engages in the
protesting by taking the stress the
street of Iran's Stone and villages with
the motto women life freedom
the death of Masha amini at the age of
22 as a result of brutal attacks by the
morality police for a poorly adjusted
Veil
triggered massive protests through this
large population of 85 million people
women's are in front of the protests
that has been joined since then by a
very large population mixed population
of young men and women student high
school student managers pension pension
people more age people so I'm really
happy to see this contest in the street
of Iran last week we had a long plenary
debate with vice president our high
representative Mr Borel and he adopted a
Resolute and we adopted a resolution
voted by a very large majority
our intervention today is not to repeat
the plenary debate but to go even
further with our three guests
our three guests are first doctor
professor of Sociology a director of the
soundtrack
senior reporter and present presenter of
talk show program in Iran TV
International TV and Taha SE berifa
researcher in the Middle East and North
Africa division of Human Rights Watch
I will directly give them the floor I'm
I'm really proud to have you here with
us to continue to work on this issue uh
it is not only to have a statement on
the situation of Johan it's important of
course to show our
so yeah important to show our solidarity
for Iranian people being in the street
but it is also important for us to find
way of helping these protests in the in
the country for the rights for the right
of women of course but for the right of
people in general in Iran so I will
directly give you the floor Dr feroze
um
yeah you have eight minutes
Madam chair ladies and gentlemen I'd
like to begin first and foremost by
thanking the European Parliament
the European Parliament has always
raised awareness about human rights in
Iran amongst other plays for example
with the Sakura of prize to two
laureates in 2012.
I should also like to thank you for the
attention that you have paid to the
situation that the Iranians are
currently on going and the proposal for
a joint resolution that is also uh still
being worked on and thank you again for
this invitation Iranians need
international support
Masa is just a first
a first in a list that is growing ever
longer and indeed we can't even keep up
with all of the names this resolution is
extremely detailed in the area of human
rights as well as the exections of the
Iranian regime when it comes to
cultural religious minorities as well as
issues of environmental Defenders that
we should also perhaps mention because
they're all in prison I shan't go back
over the details that are listed out in
great D in Greater length in this Pro
this draft I would like however
to draw the attention of this honorable
assembly to
a few points that are extremely
important for Iranians they're 43 years
now this situation has been ongoing the
Iranian regime arrests kills tortures in
full impunity
and has no regard for international
norms and the protection of the citizens
of its citizens and we do see this in
broad daylight the fact that there is a
major
um scorn for public opinion moreover
what we've seen is that the regime has
drawn this out the Thera cross theocracy
the jury consult
and the terms that are used in the
country
they function and are justified
by the principles and considers that
this is completely above all other
systems the law of God stands above any
International Norms or decisions made in
assembly so legitimizing a fight against
Imperial imperialism and westernization
and that has made women the pillar of
its I its authenticity and the thereby
the control of these women a sign of
respect for those values that they
believe are endogenous any change to
this system would bring about the end of
the current ideology and that is why the
protests that are
taking place now are so incredibly
important it shows that young women no
longer want the system of the
um higher a rule of God and this a scorn
for the outside world
yes Iranians have taken to the streets
before 2009 2007 amongst others in 2019
now we know that this has been for
economic reasons it has been for
political reasons but this time it's
different
this time there is a calling into
question a re-evaluation of this regime
and the regime's existence as that state
it cannot accept
directives from outside that hits at the
values an individual has no place
amongst this edifice within this edifice
what prevails is the system that is why
appeals aside calls for order these are
legitimate these are desirable these are
necessary but we have to hit at the
hardcore the ruling class that has all
impunity and that doesn't respect even
themselves their their own principles
it's full hypocrisies
children are outside without
in foreign countries and do what they
and do as they please but the young
people in the country are dying
corrupted systems are elsewhere whereas
Iran suffers from poverty some 50 of the
population lives under the poverty line
ladies and gentlemen
I'm
truly extremely concerned about the
reactions from this regime that has
nothing left to lose because in the face
of these demonstrations what is at stake
here is there very the very survival of
the regime thank you very much thank you
for rules you have the flow for eight
minutes
thank you everyone okay I'm a journalist
so I'm going to give you a latest of
what is happening I um put a note on my
Twitter and I said that I'm I will be
speaking at the human rights
subcommittee of
um at the European Parliament so what do
you want me to say I had a reply which
brought tears in my into my eyes someone
from sanandas wrote that don't please do
mention us sanandaj is a city in north
um
west of Iran there has been massive
gunshots during the last night all over
the night until the morning internet has
been shut down there is no clear number
of the injurers or people who have been
killed in yesterday's protest four
people were confirmed dead but the
number of the injured it was reported 50
still we don't know the extent
people were so worried the whole night
about the massacre that was going there
I'm I'm starting this speech with this
because any moment
for Iran for people who they put
themselves in front of the bullets
matters the sooner the International
Community comes to understanding that
they have to do something to stop this
nonsense
the more life would be saved and I know
life of people matters to you guys here
to everyone here
you're all human so you understand when
people are losing someone on the street
just because they're they're fighting
for freedom
the word that we were Hearing in Iran
was woman life Freedom since the
beginning
no one was saying anything else this is
a fight for human dignity
everyone on the street is fighting
because they have been
feeling that I mean they haven't been
represented during the last 43 years
Islamic Republic they believe they don't
it doesn't represent him they want peace
they want freedom they want to live an
ordinary life this is what people want
what do they get in response in these
demands
is bullet this is what they got in San
Andreas yesterday maribon was busy
mohabbat had the same problem yesterday
all over Iran I mean from on Saturday we
had Nationwide protests going on see the
answer was bullets in most cases we had
a video coming from Shiraz they were
beating a child we had a video from
Tehran a woman a pregnant woman was
bitten by by button and the guy beside
here they were like he was shouting that
she's pregnant don't beat her and still
she was getting patterned
on her stomach
so I'm just giving you a hint of the
pain that we are going through this is
the 23rd day that I and many journalists
who they're focusing on Iran have been
seeing all these things happening
the difference this time is that we see
all the fractions of the society getting
involved
students high school students are in the
street
University students are on the street
teachers
Ordinary People very young population we
have lost like actually the the the
victims
like it started with master who was 22
years
then we came to Hadith najafi Hadith was
22 years then it came to Nico about 16
years she had her birthday 10 days
before she was after she was killed we
had Serena Smiles at the brilliant mind
she was 16.
the average age of protesters has come
come to the teenagers
this is their Cry For Freedom this is
what they wanted to choose for their
life
I need to mention
a brilliant journalist
nilo Pharma Nilofar homedy who is in
prison now
she was the one who went to Castro
hospital and brought the news of the
master family
into the society she was the one who
brought it
into the like public opinion and she is
in prison now
the family of NASA the very brave family
who they have been extremely under
pressure
but still they speak
they're answering my questions anything
anything that the officials are saying
about them
if it's lie which really they have said
anything right
they come up they answer they they
mention what was the exact fact that was
going on and these family are under
extreme pressure I was asking one of the
members of the family the whole like he
asked for a piece of the interview that
they had done before and I was wondering
what happened and he was just like no
nothing happened I mean the Securities
are putting still pressure on us
but everyone is okay
like life-wise they are still alive
what people are expecting from
the international Society they expect
International Society to understand
their situation and come up with a
resolution come up with the measures
come up with an answer
human right has to be put on on the
agenda it has to be placed on top of the
priority in any negotiation any
political relationship with the bus with
any any country
so far it has not been included as much
as people were suffering inside Iran a
government is representing them that
necessarily doesn't care about their
well-being
targeted sanction could be really really
helpful in order to bring the government
into the understanding that they have to
do to take it serious they cannot kill
people on the street and yet
expect the international Society to
treat them
as a rational state
last Friday in zohedon there was a
massacre
so far Tara separity can like can
correct me I mean she she's an expert on
human rights but
um as far as I know there has been 185
um deaths like in the government
Crackdown 19 or under 18 years old
90 of these 185 were killed in after
Friday prayers in a matter of hours
in few hours
and no one heard about it or if they
heard it it was very briefly not to the
extent of this care that people
experienced there
a doctor put a picture on their
Instagram I'm so sorry for taking your
time I hope that I still have a little
bit of time like one minute I'll finish
it up but the there was a doctor a
surgeon put a picture of a bullet taken
out of the back of a 13 years old
and he was saying that I mean you shot
him at the back
are you human
and then the next day no one heard about
that doctor he's disappeared we don't
know where he is
as
simple as that
I want EU
to come into an understanding that
arresting citizens of EU is not
arresting is shaking
why don't you recognize it as the right
Point like right aim for it
it is hostage taking as friends like two
days ago announced it finally after all
these years they arrest EU citizens
and at the end of the day I mean it's it
has to be acted accordingly there is a
term for it in international law
so address it properly it's a hostage
shaken by a government a state state is
acting irrational the answer has to be
strong otherwise it's not going to stop
Iran and Russia are backing each other
if EU did something which was right for
Russia you can do it for a run
I didn't
what we want what all humans want is a
simple thing we want the right for woman
we want the right to live we want to lie
the right to have freedom thank you
thank you Seema for this testimony I
give now the flow to Taha uh
yeah
you have the flock
and thank you so much can you hear me
okay yeah perfect
okay great and thank you so much um for
the invitation and I greatly appreciate
the opportunity to brief the members the
members of the subcommittee about the
ongoing situation
um and I want to Echo the thanks raised
by previous speakers to actions that
have already been been taken by the
European Parliament and the approach the
widespread protest in Iran that were
spark sparked by the death of 23 year
old maso Gino amini in the death of
Iran's in the custody of Iran's morality
police and have entered their fourth
week
um the intensity of Street protests are
buried but they have they have been
consistent and they have spread to
universities as well as high schools
across the country
um I'm sure
um many of you have seen the iconic
images of women and girls in the streets
in Iran and their bold acts of defiance
but I think it's important to emphasize
and the significance of these protests
and why they are so unique I think first
and foremost these protests are of great
significance because women are the
leading agent for change they have taken
the leading role in framing the message
and calling for uh for um being
recognized
um as equal members in the society that
calls
um that were initially about
accountability for the death of maso
amini and and against the entire
compulsory hijab laws have gone much
broader to Target the autocratic core of
the system and I think it's because
people who are in the street as well as
those who are supporting them in my
opinion correctly understand that these
are not isolated cases they very well
understand that and the compulsory her
job laws which are a symbol of systems
attempt to control every aspect of
people's life is very well connected to
the undemocratic and autocratic nature
of the system
these protests have very much replicated
Decades of fight by by women to gain
equal rights and autonomy they're very
widespread they're intersectional
they're beyond ethnic ethnic divides a
wall and protests are being led in many
of the minority minor minority majority
areas in the country they have very
broad National support and they're led
by by youth but the cause is supported
by um
by a broad by broad segment of the
society so I think understanding the
significance of this protest and how
um they have come to be and how they are
basically
um both the continuation of the
decades-long fight for greater equality
as well as a much more visible
manifestation of the the growing
discontent with this with the situation
is important
um I'm not sure where the protests are
gonna go but I think regardless of where
the protests are gonna go they've
changed the conversation
about many aspects of risk repression in
Iran about the compulsory hijab laws
about the about authorities treatment of
peaceful protesters and I think it's
important to acknowledge that I want to
spend a few minutes on and giving you
more specifics about Authority's
response to this protest and I want to
end by what human Swatch has been
calling for
um for for accountability
um
Iranian security and intelligence
apparatus have resorted to some of their
most known measures to respond to these
protests
um at Human Rights Watch we have
documented use of lethal and excessive
force against largely peaceful protests
across Iran we've documented use of
handguns
um classical pattern assault rifles and
we have seen injuries that are
consistent with use of
ammunition that should not be used to
disperse um to disperse protesters even
if they are not 100 peaceful
um we have spoken to eyewitnesses who
have told us about how they've seen
people being shot by bullets who are
fleeing from the protests and and posed
no see no no risk to the security
establishment the total number of deaths
and injuries are extremely difficult to
comp to compile because we are we are
experiencing widespread internet
shutdown and disruption in Iran as well
but what we can tell with confidence is
that dozens of people have been shot and
killed by security forces and use of
unlawful and lethal Force
um our research does not include the
bloody Crackdown that the previous
speaker mentioned that's been extremely
deadly and we were working on
documenting the exact scale of that but
it's important to note that in areas
remote from from the capital with less
access and use of force have been even
more brutal and the casualties have been
have been much higher
I think it's also important to mention
that um assault aside from the brutal
response to the protests authorities
have also embarked on
um all-out campaign of arresting
remainders of women's women's rights
Defenders human rights Defenders
political activists journalists and and
even lawyers who have been trying to
show supporters speak out about these
protests outside the protests they have
arrested or called for inter-education
public figures and celebrities they're
doing everything in their power to
um to silence growing support for for
for what we see in the streets and
universities and schools in Iran
um so when they when they say that they
are willing to recognize rights for
peaceful right for peaceful protest all
you need to look into to prove them the
hypocrisy and of the argument is to look
at the decades long repression and
authorities response to previous rounds
of protests over the past several years
with this in mind
we have several recommendations for the
International Community to respond to
this protests and I think first and
foremost I have to say that messages of
public solidarity from across the world
matters a great deal to Iranians
especially messages from
um from communities that are not usually
outspoken and I am mentioning is this
because I think European Parliament can
play an important role in out in
Outreach to other Parliament and other
entities around the world particularly
in global South and non-western
countries to also raise their voice and
support the rights of Iranian people and
as previous speakers mentioned this is
this is a movement that is calling for
greater respect for human rights and
supportive those rights should be in the
interest of Iranian in interest of the
global Community but we're also asking
for um
for member states to lead to help with
establishing a mechanism that could lead
a U.N LED investigation into patterns of
excessive use of force that we and other
Human Rights group have documented that
the most brutal Crackdown that we have
documented against the protest was in
November of 2019 but
um I don't need to go into detail about
the geopolitical aspects and incidents
of the past four years to why this
mechanism has not been established but I
think it's urgently needed and timely
and and we are calling on members of the
Human Rights Council and general
assembly to look into establishing and
establishing a mechanism with Pathways
to accountability we're also asking um
asking
um all concerned states to look into
imposing targeted human rights sanctions
on authorities that are playing a
crucial role in this Crackdown as well
as those who are
um who are committing serious human
rights violations related to the protest
including
including the infrastructure of internet
access that is intended to disconnecting
Iranian from from each other and from
the global Community
um and I think with that I will stop my
remarks and allow for for questions and
answers and I would be very happy to
provide more information about about the
state of the Crackdown and and other
issues thank you thank you tada
uh I give the floor now to the members
so perhaps first uh did Mark if you want
for for the snd I don't I don't think
Epp I don't know if there Mr Lego is
connected just one minute is Mr Leger
willing to take the floor
because I don't know if he's connected
from yes okay that's it you have the
floor I I thought you were there for the
previous uh discussion
I was here for both and I am so sorry
that I couldn't join you in person and
meet you today thank you so much for
these very strong and powerful
testimonies it's important for us to be
reminded why our support is so important
um last week I was the initiator and
negotiator of the Iran resolution from
my party and in the resolution European
Parliament condemned the Crackdown as
you know against the women of Iran and
during the negotiations I also wanted to
include a paragraph on an EU care
designation of the Islamic revolutionary
guard corpse the forces were every day
committing brutal crimes and human
rights violations against the women in
Iran but unfortunately the rest of the
groups did not want to include this in
the resolution so I mean even the EU us
sister released at the rgc and I think
that it's very important that the EU
follows so my questions on that are what
are your thoughts on on Terra
designating the irgc do you think that
the EU or more countries should do that
and if not then why not and how would a
terrorist designation affect your work
in your respective fields will the Human
Rights Watch conduct a study on the
potential igc Terra designation but also
after listening to you
I also wanted to to to ask I mean we
know how important it is with support
from our our countries and our member
states what are your thoughts on when
high level representatives from the EU
what are the parts of the world or Our
member states visit Iran and abide by
covering their hair and varying a whale
then they get there how does that affect
the the
struggle that you are doing right now
but thank you
thank you David ditmar you have the
floor for yes indeed
thank you Maria thank you Maria
and thank you
for that
very detailed overview of this terrible
regime that is going against
everything here and is doing what can
only be described as state terrorism
I think
I think that here this is a revolution
in Iran that's going to become a part of
world history is this how it's being
seen in the West
the women's opposition to the mother
regime
is
involving
um various different uprisings and
perhaps they would end if there were
some sort of reforms but here we've got
a free we've got peaceful protests which
are being struck down with violence
and the regime is torturing and killing
people and throwing countless
numbers in jail
people have been oppressed for decades
and this would be calling for nothing
less than the downfall of the regime and
this is why I would like to say that the
consequences need to happen the European
Parliament was mentioned earlier and I
think that what has been done could be
built upon what we need is clear
solidarity with the people in Iran
we need more targeted stricter sanctions
against the regime we need to make it
clear that human rights are
non-negotiable so I have questions
over the past few days we saw a video
where Security forces were
in a demonstration and we're
demonstrating alongside the people I
have a question therefore
what about these Security Forces who
change sides are they the same as the
people who are hitting people and then
secondly there were attacks on the
Kurdish era in Iran yesterday Above All
In xanadai
what do you know about that and then
finally I have another question what
demands do you have for European
politicians do you think it would be
right for example
to look at the talks with Iran about the
atomic agreement and to stop them thank
you
um I give the floor to anonym because I
I see nobody from renew no so Anna for
the greens
we have seen this deadly cycle so often
in Iran first outrageous Injustice
committed by the regime like now the
killing of jinamasa omini
protests in the streets then the
internet has been shut down and that's
when the beating and the killing starts
and many young people who are I mean the
future of this wonderful country end up
dead and then it's silence again an
impunity
and we wait a year or two when it all
starts again
my daughter is 16 so she's as old as
Nico shakurami
who has been killed for a video where
she's singing and dancing without a
hijab and I have to say since a few
weeks I'm just wondering how would I
feel if my daughter were out there in
the streets of Iran
I guess I would be a little proud but
before all I would be scared to death
but there is also hoping that something
you share that things are different this
time that
these young because these young people I
mean men and women know how dangerous
the situation is and still they are
going out to the streets they go out and
protest they take off their hijab and
this time they don't run away from the
security forces
but they stand there and they scare away
the security forces that's different
they do that in many cities around the
country and they have solidarity from
their parents and grandparents and today
even workers from the oil factories stop
their work and they went out to the
streets and that's something we have
seen the last time in 1973.
and we have men and women around the
world who stand up in a feminist
solidarity Movement we see all these
um artists for example cutting their
hair
we see so many people sharing the very
few messages that we get out of Iran
and
I can just say for me it's quite clear
if they beat one of our sisters in Iran
10 of us will just speak up loud and I
think that's something we see as well
and this makes a huge difference
and as politician it is my job well it
is our jobs to do everything that
finally we break this vicious cycle of
killing and impunity and silence and to
make sure that this time
the people are not out in the streets
for nothing and Sima you you said it um
it's important to make human rights the
first priority in everything we do we
also have to sanction those who are
killing people
and we have prepared sanctions for at
least 16 I hope this will happen soon
and I hope there will be more
we have to be fast and decisive we also
have to never be quiet about what is
happening in Iran we need to protect
those who are already in Exile as you
are because you are under threat and the
threat is increasing the more the regime
comes under pressure and we have to
acknowledge that and do something about
it and we have to make sure that
everyone who needs to live urgently Iran
can do that here also we have to become
better all of that is in our European
Parliament resolution but we have to
make it happen and I think some hacking
to help those in Iran circumvent the
internet blockade is also going to help
because at the moment what we get
reliably is regime propaganda what we
don't get is information from what is
actually happening in the country
but we also have to be clear to
ourselves colleagues we will not be able
to bring freedom to Iran from out here
and it is our duty therefore to do
everything we can to make sure that
those who protest in the streets do not
do that for nothing and that finally we
will see some change in Iran
but also hopefully more and more places
being ruled in the spirit of jinjiad
assadi rather than suppressive
patriarchy and we already see in
Afghanistan things are also happening
because people look to Iran
so to The Experts here today just two
questions
um the first one what more do you see
that we as the European parliamentarians
that we are can do concretely
um to have an impact on the situation in
Iran
and one remark also to you Maria Arena
the human rights committee of the German
bundestag has issued a joint statement
from all political parties in support it
would be quite nice also picking up on
what farta said that maybe we can do
that 27 times plus us
thank you Anna I give the photo Miguel
Miguel from the left
Graphics thank you Maria
thank you chair
first as of someone on the left I'd just
like to State my solidarity unnuanced
with the women and with the people of
Iran who are taking to the streets and
who are crying out to defend their
rights along with the Kurdish people who
are suffering from uh
oppression in Iran now we can see yet
again that women and first and foremost
the feminist movement are first in line
in fighting authoritarianism in the
world in the case of Iran shows that how
much the feminist movement is about in
the avant-garde how women are in the
event Vanguard in fighting the
patriarchy the patriarchy on the body of
the women tries to defend certain
principles and women therefore have this
free decision uh decision uh power over
their bodies and in Iran and yet again
they need to be able to make the
decision as to whether or not they are
going to wear a headscarf and the
barbarianism of the ayatollahs and any
other type of act that we are currently
witnessing could be the uh pretext for a
um islamophobic campaign where they
would state that we're going to try to
determine
um the backs of the bodies of women
exactly what should be done and we
should condemn this in no uncertain
terms we also hope that the European
Commission
to make sure that the Iran that uh that
Iran is not used by a place for Afghani
refugees
do you remember the commission put forth
a year ago that they would support the
Irani regime to slow the arrival of
those people who were coming to Europe
we have to just recall this now just one
year on who we wanted to pay to do our
Dirty Work this is important important
because human rights cannot be a um
um negotiating chip now we have to
remember that many revolutions began
with women
requesting peace bread and democracy
let us hope that this revolution that is
currently
rolling out in Iran will begin with this
feminist movement that's asking for
Freedom rights and democracy thank you
evina
thank you very much here and thanks to
our guests for being with us today and
sharing your testimonies the words are
not enough for us to be able to show our
solidarity and our hearts is indeed with
all of you and with all of those that
are in Iran right now
the
human rights and women rights are under
attack in Iran in Afghanistan in many
parts of the world
and I must say that I'm ashamed that the
International Community that includes
the EU have not acted rapidly and I'm
sorry for that from the side of the
European Parliament as my colleagues
already mentioned I'm so sorry
um
we we adopted a resolution last week
and then
my containing of course with concrete
actions that we would like the EU
including the member states to take
but we see the attack in in as I said in
Iran
um and we see it in Afghanistan and we
see it wherever extremits feel power
whether it is Iran 1979 whether it is
Afghanistan 2021 the feminist Revolution
that is taking place right now in in
Iran that you have been talking about
have really shown the people power that
exists in Iran women girls allies have
had enough and yes it is about ending
gender apartheid but it is also a part
of a very long ongoing Democratic
revolutions uh that that have taken a
place
um to um to end all kinds of Oppression
whether it is oppression about on women
on minorities ethnic group all kind of
Oppression that exists within Iran
when all people in Iran Kurds baluch
azeri Baha'i and Persian have shown
their tremendous courage at least what
we can do from the side of the
International Community including EU is
of course to act the slogan genjian
azadine that I've heard and grown up
with myself
um All Through The Years started in one
part of Kurdistan in the Turkish part
which went then to Syria and ended up in
the Iranian pod where jinamasa mini
comes from and ended up in whole Iran
and the whole world women and girls have
all through history as you very rightly
pointed out in every corner of the world
have gone in the Forefront of
revolutions and ask for Change and we
will continue from the side of the
European Parliament show solidarity
through protesting through
manifestating but we also so needs to go
from words to actions so my two very
concrete question is
what are the strongest concrete actions
that you would like us to take and what
is missing within the resolution that we
adopted last week in the European
Parliament that you would like to
highlight and the second is also that I
would like to pick your brain on is the
cooperation between
opposition groups in Iran different
groups in the country and the way
forward and once again our solidarity is
with you and all the freedom fighters on
the streets of Iran and your freedom is
our freedom and we will continue
standing up for your rights until the
day that the Mula dictatorship is Fallen
thank you Evin
um I I will give you the flow now to
perhaps to react uh to what have been
said and also to the question and the
main question is what can we do more
um on on this situation I think it's
really important to understand what is
possible to do and also to understand
what we as Parliament can do uh of
course we can give solidarity and
support and this is really the first
thing and it is why we are here and
giving the opportunity to people to have
the flow here and to be heard by the
rest of the world so this is the first
thing that we can do the second thing is
to make pressure to our executive
um and when you speak about targeted
sanctions it is a mechanism that can be
taken by the council not by the
parliament so saying that there is a
very strong majority here at the
European Parliament to support this
targeted sanction is important but we
don't have this capacity to decide about
this sanctions
it's important to say that because
sometimes people I said you are speaking
speaking and speaking and you are not
acting but it's because the ACT is not
coming from the parliament the ACT is
coming from the council or the high
representative presenting into the
council this is really important so we
are here to make this pressure and to
have this Consciousness about how to
change it and what is really important
is what you said is it is not only in
this Parliament but it it is also to
give the opportunity to the global South
to have an expression on this because it
is seen as a western
against Global South it is not when we
are speaking about human rights
women's rights it is universality of the
rights it is not the rights from the
Western it is not the right from the
south it is the right for everybody
and we are doing the same thing for all
countries if you have these rights being
violated in other countries we are doing
exactly the same in this committee
um and I I wanted to say that because we
don't we don't want to be seen as
manipulated by some and defending the
rights in some case and not in the other
case and what we are trying to do in
this committee is to avoid these double
standards
when we have double standards at the
European level we are losing credibility
so what we are asking here for women's
in Iran it is what we are asking here
for women in Afghanistan for women in
the Gulf countries for women in Latin
America for women in Africa in Nigeria
in other countries it is what we are
doing here whatever Wherever Whenever
there are it is the fight that we have
to have without these double standards
and so this is really the message the
message that we have to convey to the
people that are listening to to us uh on
on this situation so but I give you
directly the floor if they are reaction
and if there are questions you wanted to
react on so you have the flows first
yeah
thank you
I will answer some of the questions
and then I will
give the floor to my neighbor and others
to answer as well firstly I'd like to
say that
I've been working on Afghanistan and
Iran for more than 40 years so that
means most of you weren't even born when
I look around here I've followed the
different
episodes in the different periods in the
two countries and I think that it is
important to talk about to the both of
them at the same time firstly
I think when I'm thinking about things
that the European Parliament can do
because I am aware that you have said
that the parliament cannot take a
retaliation measures so it's in a
difficult position
in that way but the first thing to do is
to understand what
the
um
headscar's mean for Iran at the moment
it's the basis of this regime they are
trying to show how authentic they are
and to show their disdain for the
International Community to say that they
are authentic Muslims and that they do
not care what others may say so if you
haven't understood that then you cannot
understand
what it means to take it off then
because these young girls
are saying that we want to be part of
the International Community but the
regime of course has to defend its
position
so well for the past 40 years
a lot well a lot has happened over the
past 40 years and even at the very start
even in the preamble to the Iranian
Constitution we know what the terms are
they're written very clearly women do
not have any
um space at all they're made to
procreate and we know that they're being
pushed to stay at home today because
they have been asked to
um have children they're trying to
increase the population to 150 million
and
contraception for example has been cut
so
women
haven't been supported for a long time
now and the regime knows it and that's
the problem here the regime knows that
the West
and here I do think there is some room
for maneuver but the regime thinks that
the West is going to
um
withdraw and they're counting on that so
you shouldn't be doing that you
shouldn't be withdrawing and going
backwards you you shouldn't forget about
them you talk about the Afghan woman the
Afghan woman
were in the media
for several months and then that was it
because something else came along
and
they're just forgotten about there are
other tragedies we've got Ukraine of
course
it is at the top of everyone's
preoccupations and concerns but you must
not forget them that's the first
recommendation do not forget them and
support very clearly Iranian women and
Afghan woman but I'd like to just turn
to you and ask what you are ready to do
because
you need to know that as well what are
you prepared to do how far are you
prepared to go to defend
your values our values
and that the Iranian woman want to share
as well
are you going to go as far as
questioning the regime
as is currently happening when it comes
to Putin of course it's hard
even the issue of sanctions is a very
complicated issue because
sanctions will
make it even more complicated for a
Iranian woman as well and so that's why
I would say you really need to Target
the regime
and I don't often support that kind of
things but don't give them the
permission to come have Bank sanctions
don't let their children come here don't
accept them because where are they
supposed to go
okay A revolution but you
chess the Iranians are chasing away the
leaders well what are they going to do
where are they going to go so that's
what they're going to do that's why they
will fight until the end
because they know they don't have any
other option thank you Mercier
some parts
um when I say that we have to have
targeted sanction I want to pick it up
from that side
um the officials and the immediate
families has to be targeted not all
Ordinary People it has to be definitely
targeted to people who are involved last
week Canada announced 10 000 people
have been banned from entering Canada
under
um was is going to be seized
because they're involved in suppressing
people
and they were part of this Crackdown
system
ten thousand
still is not enough but at least it's a
good number much better than 16.
um
the system is pretty big it doesn't
include only very few top officials that
you can Target most of these people who
they are involved in time like in
cracking down the protests they are
extremely against the people's freedom
their children are living a very wealthy
luxury life in Europe and Canada and
America you can't believe it they live
it totally a different Lifestyle the
Islamic Court in standard doesn't belong
to them it's for people who they are
inside Iran so they want something for
people who they live inside Iran because
it's an ideology of the state
at the same time their family can live
with the with the mass fraud and the
rest of the things that we have in the
country they can live abroad in peace
easy life
and that's what is proven like I mean
denied to the rest of the country
um
again I mean hostage taking is something
that I really want you to take it
serious
they're not arresting EU citizens in
Iran their
taking hostage and then they ask for
ransom you have seen it so it's better
if you take it serious
someone um no okay I'm going to to
um the points that I have someone
mentions um I don't remember which one
beside my apologies if I didn't um take
the names but it was about the
propaganda of the state and the way that
it's
um
like on preventing that need information
dissemination this is the serious
problem they do whatever they want to
censor the information they I come from
Iran International
we broadcast on several satellites we
have seen orbital jamming on every
single one of them
every single one of them our families
have been threatened I am a journalist I
haven't committed any crime
I haven't seen my mother's fat mother's
home for 17 years
I don't know where my mom lives I don't
see our home
and it's not just me many of the
journalists who they live abroad and
they're like I mean they are the only
channel that the west and the world is
getting information from inside Iran
they put their lives their family
everyone in danger the families are
threatened inside Iran their brothers
mothers sisters has been taken for
interrogation because they want to put
pressure
on journalists not to report on the
specific topics to give up their job not
to do the the journalism things that
they're doing because they don't want
the news to come out of Iran
jamming is something very important the
government doesn't does it but it
doesn't get any reaction
all has been going and like going going
for for years and years and I don't know
when International Community is going to
finally honor the freedom of speech
freedom to access information
to the whole like human beings
um there is one more Port um
about
um Iraqi Kurdistan the attack has been
going on on many cities inside Iran
especially the city of sanandas has been
under massive clashes and specifically
Gone Gone fires during the last night as
I mentioned earlier we don't know the
extent on the other side I mean they
have been targeting the Iraqi Corazon to
put pressure on the Iraqi political
parties in order to get involved
they were very boys because they we have
seen on incredible unbelievable sense of
unity within Iran for 43 years Iran
Islamic Republic was telling everyone
that if we leave the country if we are
not here you are going to lose your um
security you are going to be like Syria
you're going to be like Libya you're
going to be like Iraq
with the sense of unity that we get from
Iran
you were the ones that we always were
trying to create crackers and then sit
on the crackers in order to sell your
security to the people
people were chanting
interbreeze to support Kurdistan people
were chanting in toront of support on
the sense of unity is unbelievable this
is a revolution which brings love and
culture and everything else that has
been taken from the country for so long
there has been reports that last year
the long-con base of irgcs has been
going to the north of northwest of Iran
close to the San Andreas and the Border
area
some expect that there might be another
attack coming on the political parties
on that side of the Border or on like on
citizens unarmed citizens inside Iran's
so we are still waiting to see how it's
going to go
um
you mentioned Nikka and you're 16 years
old
yesterday Nico's mother had an interview
like the government has been telling the
story about the people who they have
died so far two cases that the girls
were participating in the demonstration
they were taken they were bitten they
were killed then the government comes
into the national States television and
says that oh they jumped out of a very
high building
that was the story said the mother put
her life in danger and she came and she
released the video first then she did an
interview with Iran International Art
Channel and then she spoke to one of the
inside
um press like the newspapers
what she said she said that I want
everyone to know our story
I want the world to know my story this
is exactly her words
yesterday she said that I'm very happy
finally
because I mean when I think more I know
that my daughter
you're talking about the 16 years old my
daughter died for something that she
believed in
what we believe what what I would like
to ask from you to get into to take into
consideration is that
Islamic Republic is a threat
to everyone to people inside Iran who
they are chanting Freedom they are
seeking freedom and their response is
bullet to the people in the region
because Iranian people have no fight
with anyone
we don't want to have proxies anywhere
so
not
many people believe
especially the voices from Iran I'm not
allowed to say the names but I received
a note from
let me read it to you I'm sorry let me
take this opportunity
this message came from Iran from a woman
who I'm not allowed to tell her name
because she is out of prison by Bay but
she was she spent seven years in prison
she's a very well known person if I say
the name you would not you would know
what I'm talking about but I'm not going
to say that
but she sent me a message
okay this is a message from people
um like people who designed this one
some are inside the prison now and some
are outside with bail so they couldn't
really reveal
we want from all International
communities and governments too first
Islamic Republic
cut your political and diplomatic ties
with this corrupted
and Criminal
and terrorists
state
close your
um
embassies
expand their diplomas because what they
do outside of the country is just like
they they participate in
terrorist Acts as
the Diplomat who was accused of
terrorism and was put in jail in Belgium
and Hamid Nuri is the one who has been
tried in Sweden and he is also in prison
so their place is behind the bars not to
go back to Iran
you have to expel that the former
political officials of Islamic Republic
who they have been involved in criminals
in crime acts actions of the government
and then they have stayed in the west
and still are defending the Islamic
Republic's activities such as Terror of
Salman Rushdie
um their families
who they left Iran with Millions
of money which has been stolen from
people of Iran they have to be under
um investigation
and their money has to be seized
in benefit of people of Iran I'm so
sorry if the translation is not very
good because this is reason enforcement
I'm just reading it
um
from a 40 version
um you have to stop letting the artist
and
um four times
to participate in
games festivals and all those like
international events
because they represent Islamic Republic
you did it for Islip for South Africa
and at that time
in the 80s many countries came to the
aid of people in South Africa to
put an end into the South African
apartheid why don't you do it for Iran
bye bye
woman life freedom
thank you thank you Sima for these words
um I give the floor now to the inpa no
sorry yes yeah it's uh
no Deputy head uh of division task force
Nita sorry
thank you very much Madam chair and
thank you very much to to the speakers
and for their insights and also for the
comments and the statements by the
members of the European Parliament
um
you mentioned the resolution which has
been adopted last week by the European
Parliament on this very matter and we
can only fully Echo the
the dismay that we feel about the
killing of uh most Dominion the police
custody and also about the violent
Crackdown of peaceful protesters so you
also mentioned
High representative
attending the debate in European
Parliament last week and I think he he
used very clear words in this regard and
fully echoing also the Declaration that
he issued on 25th of September on behalf
of your member states there was a very
strong political joint signal from our
science uh in this regard so uh the
message is very clear stop immediately
the the violent Crackdown uh release the
those which are detained uh access
internet or or allow free flow of
information and last but not least uh
ensure accountability not only for the
death of masamini but also for all the
violent Crackdown that has been
happening happening since so I think uh
these are very strong and clear messages
that have been passed by by the EU and
by high representative on behalf of you
member states
and
you many of you mentioned the issue of
restrictive measures or sanctions and
that that option indeed has been one of
the elements of the the Declaration of
high representative and 25th of
September he himself mentioned it last
week in a debate that active
consideration is currently being given
by by member states in view of the
Foreign Affairs Council which is due to
take place next Monday
um and this is fully consistent with the
overall approach that we have uh on Iran
uh we have the council conclusions back
in 2019 that have been uh supported
unanimously by all member states we have
on one side dialogue where there is
mutual interest and there is a very
critical engagement on the other side
and on human rights there is this
critical engagement we have human rights
uh sanctioned regime we have wmdu wmd a
central regime so we have sanctions but
also dialogue and this is fully
consistent with the overall approach and
I can reassure you that and also as high
rep did so many times that we use any
regular bilateral contact we have with
the Iranian side in order to raise human
rights issues in a very bespoken and
targeted matter
so um
just want to uh to fully Echo what
you're saying and and thank you very
much for your insights and you can rest
assured that we are following this very
very closely
thank you everybody for attending this
meeting it was really interesting to
hear from you uh and you will be always
welcome to this house uh to speak about
women's rights human rights and to
defend them so
um we are there for you so thank you
um
I think it's the end of this committee
today so see you on the 26th and the
27th of October for the next meeting
and so now we have to go and vote in uh
offit thank you thank you